that lets doctors prescribe an
end-of-life pill to terminally ill
patients is now approved in the state
senate it passed by one vote 11 Senators
for the bill 10 against it Democrats who
voted for it say it lets people die with
dignity the opposing side argues the
bill doesn't have enough safeguards
Senate Bill 239 authorizes a patient who
suffers from an incurable and and
irreversible condition
that according to reasonable medical
judgment will result in death within six
months to self-administer a medication
that is designed to end the life of the
patient the real risk of subtle coercion
and undue influence that assisted
suicide poses
it now heads over to the state assembly
for a vote and then if it passes it will
go to the governor's desk